[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's Brandi Carlile Fantasia Andra day
and Alicia Cara paying tribute to the
late Aretha Franklin in Aretha a Grammy
celebration for the Queen of Soul the
special which airs tomorrow night here
on CBS was co-produced by Clive Davis
who for four decades was close friends
with the legendary artist Aretha
Franklin already had a decade of hits
behind her when she met Clive Davis in
1979 where's this taken clip the Beverly
Hills Hotel so this is literally the
beginning of your French yes it was
Davis a veteran record executive was
then running the heiress to label and I
get this call from Aretha she was in a
bit of a slump at that point she was in
a bit of Islam yes but she was the Queen
of Soul yes and she said you know I'm
nearing 40 and I'm nervous that you know
can and I have hits after 40 I said
listen to me your time was so Davis
signed Aretha and in 1982 helped her
jump back on the charts with jump to it
if you were in scared like old grey
daughter's do she got nervous she was a
perfectionist when she came to the
studio she knew every line she would
only do three takes I mean no other
artist does fewer things
than what Ariba did
[Music]
in 1985 when freeway of love gave Aretha
her biggest hit in a dozen years her
comeback was complete Davis who's never
liked business dinners always made an
exception for Aretha I too always knew
that Aretha was history and I just knew
that as much as we could share or soak
up and it was special I just felt
special in return
Aretha honored Clive by appearing at a
Friars Club tribute to him the curtain
goes up and there's Aretha in the tutu
and she is surrounded by 12 members of
the city sent to ballet she had taken it
so seriously and for two months she had
rehearse with the City Ballet and before
she sank gloriously she did do this
ballet that as I said I'll never forget
so there are all many sides of Aretha
yes they were all Aretha a Grammy
celebration for the Queen of Soul
features Jennifer Hudson
[Music]
and John Legend this special was
important to you it's important that her
legacy be preserved that we all
understand that there might not ever be
another Aretha Franklin